changement de comportement si les
Français ont pu être méfiants avec les
achats sur Internet c'est de moins en
moins le cas aujourd'hui le montant des
ventes via l'ordinateur a doublé il
pourrait atteindre 10 millions d'euros à
la fin de l'année les sites internet qui
proposent de la vente affichent donc une
belle santé à tel point que certains
entrent en bourse Jean samac Hervé
Gutman cet avocat fait 80 % de ses
achats sur Internet même pour équiper
son cabinet en matériel informatique il
a eu recours au ce en ligne des
ordinateurs au scanner tout y est passé
et pour cet homme dont l'emploi du temps
est très serré acheté en ligne est
devenu un geste naturel numéque il est
évident aujourd'hui que je n'ai pas les
moyens d'aller faire trois magasins qui
seront probablement situés à des
endroits extrêmement ave des quartiers
différent dans Paris ça va me prendre 3
ou 4 heures alors qu'aujourd'hui en 10
minutes un quart d' maximum j'ai fait
mon choix sur Internet et le site favori
de ce fa rue d'informatique s'appelle
rudeducommerce.com une entreprise
florissante un million de clients 180
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
c'est bien qu'aujourd'hui elle entre en
bourse le matériel est entreposé ici à
Lyon mais pour le reste pas de boutique
classique juste une boutique virtuelle
ah c'est magnifique vous prenez un
magasin traditionnel vous avez vous avez
1000 m² d'espace pour vendre 500
références donc les 1000 m² il faut les
louer ou faut les acheter ça coûte au
moins on va dire 15 à 20 % du Chi
d'affair et et c'est sur ça que vous
avez économisé sur ça du commerce il a
un magasin il y a 10000 références dont
Patrick s'occupe et les 10000 références
c'est il y a zéro coout et ce site de
commerce en ligne n'est pas le seul à
faire des bénéfices informatique mais
aussi tourisme et loisir cette année les
achats en ligne ont été multipliés par
deux exemple un voyage sur 10 est acheté
sur le net un boom qui s'explique par
une généralisation d'internet et du au
débit mais pas
seulement il y a aussi les freins
psychologiques qui ont été levés chez
les consommates pour pouvoir accepter de
donner le numéro de cartes bleu sur
Internet ce qui était pas vraiment
pensable il y a 5 6 ans mais ce boom du
commerce en ligne ne fait pas encore
vraiment recette pour les produits
alimentaires et pour les vêtements le
shopping non virtuel a tout de même
encore de
l'avenir